si la plupart des enfants profitent
encore de leur lit en vacances c'est 23
jeunes du club de foot de l'étoile
sportive de trappes eux sont bien
matinaux mardi 26 avril il s'apprête à
embarquer pour six heures de bus
destination le musée national de la
sécurité sociale alors a pas entre eux
la sécu elle football là mon peuple
ça s'appelle le collectif 6 heures du
matin départ pour lormont à côté de
bordeaux
un périple initié pour la première fois
dans le cadre de l'association pharma
citoyens avec pour objectif transmettre
aux jeunes les valeurs de la solidarité
et s'il ya quelque chose qui symbolise
bien le collectif le collectif national
c'est bien la sécurité sociale et je
voulais qu'on leur rende hommage et que
les enfants comprennent ce que c'est
qu'un collectif dans le jeu mais
également un collectif au sein de la
nation au sein de la république près de
600 kilomètres plus tard arrivée au
château des lauriers en gironde pour le
déjeuner résidence de la famille gradis
au 19e siècle le bâtiment héberge le
musée national de l'assurance maladie
depuis 27 ans et c'est la maîtresse de
maison elle même qui vient accueillir
les visiteurs venus de loin
et encore
en faisant chanter marin poilu au
messager du roi mari anthony font vivre
ses personnages sous les yeux des
enfants
maintenant on prend un plaisir énorme
parce qu'il ya une valeur qui magnifique
qui est promu dans cette visite la
solidarité mais lady du roi henri iv en
1604 qui actait pour la première fois un
chirurgien pour les mineurs ou encore la
mise en place d'un régime de protection
sociale pour les marins par aliénor
d'aquitaine
une dizaine de saynètes imaginées depuis
deux ans pour apprendre aux jeunes les
étapes importantes de la création de la
sécurité sociale en 1945 il faut pouvoir
faire des bonds dans le temps et surtout
se remet dans des ambiances
c'est bien de parler d'une histoire de
se remettre dans un contexte historique
mais on a le matériel on a des pièces de
collection et dans cette pièce en
particulier c'est qu'on a du matériel
d'origine qui a été utilisé à partir des
années 50 entre les années 50 et 70 dans
les centres de paiement des quêtes
sécurité sociale monsieur bonjour deux
heures de visite et c'est déjà l'heure
de rentrer les jeunes trappistes font le
point sur leurs connaissances
c'est une personne qui rembourse
quant aux machines miss aniston et brad
pitt
on doit payer votre rouge et eux ils
remboursent par exemple les 15 euros
c'est l'euro qui a dit qu'ils allaient
mettre en place au début j'étais jolie
devait guère ans y est collé
les mineurs on va dès qu'on a des
problèmes au moins il ya des gens qui
peuvent lui sourit ben oui comme mon
gros boutons hommage au père comme une
devise a même été créé durant le voyage
pour résumer simplement le principe
alors pour tous le collectif s'est
effectivement ne pas jouer seul comptait
sur son voisin et faire en sorte que son
voisin soit un allié également dans
l'est dans les bars dans les difficultés
de la vie et en fait spontanément ils
m'ont dit quand est-ce qu'on reparle
quand est ce qu on fait quelque chose
c'est avec des souvenirs plein la tête
que les enfants retrouvent leurs parents
un peu à contrecoeur de voir leur
périple se termine et face au succès de
cette première initiative le club de
l'étoile sportive de trappes prévoit
déjà d'autres destinations